we hired hackers to break down our email
in fact we tried to scam them instead so
we created a mailbox in a new domain and
filled it with messages then we placed
an email in our inbox with the subject
line your login and password in the hope
that the attacker would be interested
and open the email and here's the funny
part inside it we placed a tracking
pixel a transparent picture of one by
one pixel if an attacker opens the email
on his computer the image will be loaded
from our server and we'll find out his
IP address sounds cool to hack hackers
right the Trap is ready we opened some
fishing emails from scammers and type in
our
credentials 3 Days
Later finally on the fourth someone
opened our bait email our server
recorded the IP address of the device on
which the email was opened watch the
full video to see what happens
next